my beard grows really I shaved a day and
a half ago Chad Michael Murray is all
grown up and almost unrecognizable in
his new movie outlaws and angels you and
her just know was outdated yourselves
and fix like this the 34 year olds actor
is also a dad now and he gets candid
with me about fatherhood
for the first time Henry he starts off
you think he's the bad guy he kind of
comes around and a lot of it is thanks
to this woman that he needs do you feel
any similarities to that now that you
are a family guy what having a family
does is it it just changes your
perspective on everything it was the
greatest thing that's ever happened to
me I mean having kids is just it's a
game changer and I think you're always
walking around the mentality that you
want to make sure that they're proud and
you want to represent them well and just
be a great leader and and I think that
that's really what came across well this
here's a new member of our game jadon
wife Sarah Romer welcomed their first
child last May do you feel like you
decide your roles now that you're a dad
and yeah yeah I do I do I do
just last week the project came up you
know and I just due to the content alone
it wasn't something that I need you know
my son grows up to see you really have
to weigh each choice plant Eastwood's 22
year old daughter Francesca co-stars in
the ultraviolent Western but what is her
famous brother Scott think of her steamy
scenes yeah he's very he's protective
and yeah a big brother type of wife Chad
really took me under his wing I mean
this is you know my first film he very
much was a guide very fatherly and very
and was just very supportive on your end
is it hard for Sarah to see you in those
kinds of things or does she get it cuz
she no she gets it we talk about
everything we talk about all the garb
content and we talked
everything and she is you know she comes
from this woman so she understands it he
said to me at laws and angels hits
theaters and VOD on July 15